i i looked at here in the new book it
said um
and i want to ask you about this it says
do not allow yourself to become
resentful um deceitful or arrogant
the first part of that you i've
witnessed um
and i know that you've lived and i i've
never seen an
attack on someone like i've seen on you
and i've been
i paid attention you know i'm a comedian
i'm i i talk about
cultural issues i i um
you know am relatively well versed in
what's going on in the public sphere
i've never seen uh attempt after attempt
after attempt to smear uh and like
besmirch
a human being as i saw with you i've ne
i mean there was um much
less and i'm i'm serious about this
there was
maybe less negative press about osama
bin laden
than you i mean i mean i like i i think
there was
more of like people trying to understand
osama bin laden
um you know he grew up uh you know when
he was disenfranchised or whatever it
was
but how do you not especially because
you went through this very powerful
ordeal
and i don't know how and i know that a
lot of that was internal family dynamics
and your own health and your family's
health
but how do you not become resentful
against
uh the people that have uh
tried to assassinate your character also
do you blame any of them for what you
went through
recently which we'll we'll talk about in
a little bit but you know the ordeal
that you went through do you blame any
of these people
do you do you say to yourself had they
not been as aggressive
and had they not been as vicious uh you
might not have been in the situation you
were in
well you know i worked through a lot of
the answers to the questions that you're
asking while i was writing
this second book the last chapter the
chapter you referred to do not do not
become resentful deceitful or arrogant
those are the three things that i
noticed
that were particularly catastrophic
to people in my clinical practice specif
those three things and their
interactions
um and then in the in the final chapter
chapter 12
is be grateful in spite of your
suffering um
look the first thing i'd say is that
i've watched people since i've
become public a public figure
i've watched people my my peers let's
say academics in other places
in the world or people who are roughly
my professional peers who've been the
target of attacks
on twitter or in the newspapers
in some manner similar to what's
happened to me
and my observation has been that it's
very very hard on people they generally
fold up and apologize and are shocked
and hurt
quite to a quite deep degree and so
it's no joke to
to have that happen to you it's it's
given me more insight into why people
are so likely to not say the things they
need to say
when it's the time to say them because
the trouble
that that can cause is very
uh difficult to cope with and so i
certainly wouldn't say that it's been
without effect
it's also a great mystery to me that it
continually happens
i continually expect it to stop but
it doesn't stop and i don't it's hard to
understand why that is
exactly i'm i'm trying to understand
that all the time
i think to some degree there's a public
attempt to understand that even
and i say that because i'm also the
subject of
an inordinate number of memes and
they represent who people think i am
um in a very large number of ways
strange ways i've become very associated
with lobster imagery and with frog
imagery and with
king imagery and with well the red skull
imagery and
it's a very complex set of of images and
so
that all adds to the difficulty of
sorting it out as as far as i'm
concerned
i certainly was tempted towards
bitterness
and resentment as a consequence of my
illness which created a tremendous
amount of pain
and well at the same time approximately
the same time my daughter and my wife
are also very ill and so it's difficult
not to succumb to the temptation
to shake your fist at god and curse the
clouds and the thunder
and this structure of being itself for
all the
all the suffering that people go through
but it's not helpful and i've really
strived
with the help primarily of my wife but
also of other people close to me
to identify resentful and bitter
thoughts and to eradicate them
because they're not helpful they're not
justifiable like under any condition as
far as i can tell
to and that's why i tried to
illustrate in chapter 12 that gratitude
is most properly conceptualized
if it's not naive as a form of courage
it's sort of like the decision you take
when you decide to get married
you know the trope is that you find the
right person and then
you just know but the truth of the
matter is is that you
you decide and then you continually keep
deciding day after day while you're
living with the person and
gratitude in the face of life suffering
is the same thing it's
a decision about an attitude that you
are going to strive to bring forward it
isn't so much uh
it isn't so much a uh considered opinion
about the benevolence or
lack thereof of the world right so
and i just couldn't see when i delved
into my thoughts i thought this seems
unfair i
my family is struggling under a
tremendous burden
of ill health not that that's not true
of many many families i'm
very aware of that and and at the same
time this
in some sense rather unique uh
exposure to continual public pillaring
pillorying if that's a word probably
isn't
but but i did when i delved into it
identified all the thoughts and thought
them through
i couldn't see any positive utility they
weren't helping me in any way
so and i've done a reasonable job of
dispensing with them in the last two
months i would say at the same time
however i've also been recovering
to a fair degree since i've been
properly diagnosed finally
now what was that proper diagnosis for
the people that aren't aware of what you
went through because i know that there's
there's a lot of speculation because
there was really no information out
there when you
kind of disappeared from public life
yeah it's still not exactly clear
what happened to me i've had a long
history of depression and that
definitely has played a role in
predisposing me to
whatever happened over the last few
years but
my new physician
i i was particularly suffering in the
mornings that
and by the end of the day i was back to
something approximating normal but it
would take me like eight hours or so of
real effort to even get to the point
where i could stand up
and move forward to without excruciating
pain without
believing that i was going to collapse
and then
that would recur every morning while he
investigated the structure of my sleep
and
found that i was i had severe central
sleep apnea and
i was waking up 25 times an hour so
those are stressful occurrences where
you stop
breathing and so i've been using a
breathing machine for the last
month and it's improved me from about
five percent of function to about 50 or
60 percent and
and i'm still seem to be improving at
least to some degree
and so apparently i wasn't getting
i was wearing this ring that monitors
sleep and i was getting zero deep sleep
maybe one minute or two minutes a night
which is nowhere near enough
and since i've been using the machine
it's up to more like 30 to 50 minutes
that's where your body restores itself
completely it's during deep sleep
and so at least one of the problems that
i was facing it's not the only one but
at least one of them was
chronic lack of sleep